So in packet monitoring, a monitor might
see the full packet contents, or at least
the packet headers that traverse a particular
link. Common ways of performing packet monitoring that
you may have tried yourself include tcpdump,
ethereal, or wireshark. And in some of the
exercises, you'll get a chance to Explore packet
monitoring with one of these tools. Sometimes packet
monitoring is performed using expensive hardware that can
be mounted in servers alongside the router that
forward traffic through the network. In these cases,
an optical link in the network is sometimes
split So that traffic can be both sent
along the network and sent to the monitor.
Even though packet monitoring sometimes requires this expensive
hardware on very high speed links, what you do
when you run tcpdump or wireshark or ethereal
is essentially the same thing. Your machine acts as
a monitor on the local area network. And if
any packets. Hapen to be sent towards your network
interface. The network interface records those packets. Now on
a switch network, you wouldn't see many packets that
weren't destined for your own mac address. But on
a network where there's a lot of traffic being
flooded, you might see quite a bit more
traffic destined for an interface that you're using
to monitor. So the advantages of packet monitoring
is that It provides lots of detail. You can
see timing information and information in the packet
headers. Unfortunately, a disadvantage is that it's fairly high
overhead. It is very hard to keep up
with high speed links and often requires a separate
monitoring device. Such as the monitoring card that we've shown here.
What if we are happy with a little less detail, then packet
monitoring can provide. But we can't afford its overhead? In that case,
there is actually another approach that we can use, called flow monitoring.